and
all right and with that our
our linkedin stream is live
our youtube stream is live i believe and
as you can see we have rock vendor with
us so let me introduce the session
uh
hello welcome to everyone to
secrets to
building world-class products strategies
for becoming
a world-class developer in 2022. our
guest today is
vendor gandhati who is director of
technology for sim press
i'll tell you a little more about
himself after i introduce him but first
let me let you know about the q and a
box in
webex please put your questions for
rugbendra there
you do have the option to chat to all
panelists
tend to
log the questions in for the q a segment
of the
webinar toward the end
and that's the best place to put them
we're also going to ask you a couple of
questions today or the beginning and end
of the session
so let's start with this one
if you're watching live through webex
you can see the poll widget
if not if you're on the streaming
service you can answer in the comments
basically we just want to get a feeling
for
how experienced our audience is
and we're also checking in on
how you're feeling today we've been
checking in with folks during the
pandemic because of the
rising and falling surges and the
opening and closing of businesses so
just like to get a
kind of well-being check
and we'll close the poll in about three
seconds
here's the results
it's kind of a bimodal distribution in
our audience foreign vendors we have uh
about half of our audience or folks who
are still in school but
uh the next largest group of people with
more than five years of experience so
this will be an interesting session
and
it's good to see that um
over 90 percent of the folks checked in
saying they're doing well or doing okay
so we hope this will improve the outlook
for everyone else and
with that i'm going to introduce
alexander gennady the director of
technology at simpress
who has
around 20 years of experience in the
design and development of software
systems
most recently before sempress he was the
head of software development at tesco
he is a
passionate advocate for best practices
in engineering and software development
and
i'll let him
tell a little bit more about himself now
as he starts his uh discussion welcome
rug
vendra hi uh thank you stuart and uh
good morning good afternoon good evening
uh wherever you are uh
thank you for joining this session um
about myself i think stuart has pretty
much summarized it uh well uh i have
been it's impressed for the past five
months before that i was at tesco
and over uh the last uh 20 or close to
20 years i've worked on various uh
software various facets of software
development various kinds of products uh
some enterprise products some
implementation of uh
you know
in-house solutions and currently my team
is building uh
an interesting product uh it's called
the logo maker essentially it's a
product that allows a user to
build logos with some
very simple inputs and
anyways i think i'm gonna refer
reference that a few times uh here and
there
as i go through the conversation
all right uh so let's get started uh the
the topic of the session essentially is
about world-class products but also more
importantly about uh becoming a
world-class developer
um i'll try and kind of uh talk about
the the products first and there's a
there's a strong correlation between
that and uh and
those who build those products which is
uh world-class developers such as
yourselves right
uh
typically right i think there is there's
a lot of interesting thing when it comes
to talking about products
uh there are there has been some really
good products as you
look around there have been products
that looked great but somehow did not
click
there have been some really poor
products as well right and and uh
typically i wouldn't say there is a
secret uh formula that says hey you know
you do this
you know if
this is how the product should be and so
on however uh
let me rephrase that uh there is no uh
how do i say this
there's no recipe to say that okay do
this and you get you this will become a
great product right however uh there are
certain processes there are certain
certain things that you could trust uh
to build a great product and i think
that's what i'm gonna talk about a
little bit right
uh
one of the most important things really
uh when you're building a product is
to stay and to be grounded to the space
of the problem
a lot of times
what happens is
you you try to work backwards from a
solution and say okay now let me try and
this is the solution i have and let me
try and solve the problem uh related to
that
there are some scenarios where that
works uh but usually that's not the
right direction of travel
so stay in the problem space uh do you
know what is a problem you're solving
your product the product that you're
looking to build
what is it what is the problem it is
solving uh why build this why now and
you know things like that
so it's important uh to get to a state
where you're building the right thing
before you're building the thing right
building the thing right is about the
process of how you're building it but
make sure that the problem that you're
solving you are aware of it now in some
cases of course the problem statement
itself could be that okay we are trying
to discover something discover a need so
this is a general area we would like to
operate and my instant thing is really i
want to understand uh what are the
problems and so on which is also okay
right in that case your approach will
change a little bit it will be more
experimental it will be more about
understanding your customers it's going
to be about understanding the market and
product fitment and so on which is
perfectly fine but as long but it's
important that you are aware what you're
doing it uh what you're after
because the way you would approach in
certain things certain things in the way
you would approach would change it right
especially if you are um
if you're still discovering right i
think you need to be extremely quick in
pivoting and you need to give a lot of
importance to feedback and things like
that
you have to do that even otherwise but
it's just the the relative importance
that you give to those sort of shifts
right
so yeah so and i think that's where you
know uh
state the problem space be clear about
the problem you're solving uh to code
albert einstein again i'm not sure if it
was him but this is what i read
essentially uh
there's a quotation that says uh if i
have
10 hours to solve the problem i would
spend like nine hours defining it or
a majority of the time defining what the
problem is right because once you do
that the solution becomes apparent uh
it's not always that proportion but uh
the the spirit of that is be clear about
what you're solving
uh
now
i mean and you can look around for
inspiration or look around for for
anecdotes right i mean there's some
really great products uh which uh which
which essentially what they have done is
find what like you there are a number of
different things to be done but they
found that one little pain point and
solved it iterated over it and
eventually built a great product a
simple example that comes to mind is
when facebook introduced the photo
tagging it was an experimental thing a
few engineers worked on it and the
release date they got good feedback and
they kind of built on it and uh soon
after it was a very very successful
product uh that he did
likewise there are a lot of products uh
that have
that have not done well either and
that's perfectly fine right so so we'll
we'll talk about that in a little bit
right so so understand the problem and
then something very related to that is
understand uh the customers right
understand your users who are going to
use your product
now there's a little bit of a
disambiguation required here uh because
i'm using product in a slightly broader
context right
not all software development is a pure
product in in in the sense that there is
going to be a external customer using it
right there are some great products
where the users are perhaps you know
your your colleagues or it could be
certain certain operators in your
warehouse and so on and and and those
are also really really valid and really
perfect
uh use cases but i i'm but they're not
necessarily product uh from the from the
uh from a
standard
or from a custom from a
well understood uh
terminology standpoint that i'm using
product in a broader context any
software uh that we are building uh i'm
kind of putting that as a as a product
here right and again if you follow these
right the likelihood of you building a
great product is is is too high right
uh the next thing that once you once you
know what you're building right even
though you cannot always be necessary
100 sure that this is the right thing
right so it's important uh to iterate uh
and iterate fast and repeat the process
right so it's all about hey you form an
hypothesis that this is a problem that
we'd like to solve if you try and put
something together a prototype perhaps
or or something simple
uh try it out give it to the hands of
your users get the feedback and see how
it looks and you know then you could
choose which way to proceed with whether
you want to double down or whether you
want to make some modifications and
things like that right at the end of the
day right this is the spirit of the
agile uh
uh
development methodology it it
essentially makes room for changes uh
the changes are typically uh where you
live when you learn more about your
customers when you learn more about what
problem you're solving you re-prioritize
and you sort of
shuffle up accordingly instead of
sticking to a plan and then building
something that no one is willing to use
right so so yeah so it's very important
to get uh things to the hands of the
customers to the hands of your users as
soon as possible and while you're
building uh you accept the fact that you
know you may get a few things wrong
which is okay right but you've got to
fail fast so that you could you could
sort of course correct faster and move
fast right and
uh
establishing this sort of a culture
sometimes takes time right it's not
always
straightforward in some cases it is in
some cases it's not and i think a lot of
it also depends on what you're building
uh for example uh
if it's uh
let's say it's a fairly well defined
thing right maybe you're doing a
migration of something and and you
pretty much know what you're going to
build over the next one here maybe there
are few variations in in the new system
but you have a general idea right now
these kind of systems typically have a
medium room for experimentation there
are not too many things uh that you
could experiment with because you're
fairly clear about what's what what is
it that you're building
uh
and and what i see often is uh such
systems
there is this uh there's a constant
struggle in the sense that you you want
to be agile you want to follow the scrum
and those methodologies and and for
those in the universities here uh uh
it's essentially agile principles is a
it's a methodology essentially that
allows you to uh to take small
iterations and you know instead of
having it having a big plan of
uh
delivering everything at
in a year it breaks it down into smaller
uh iterations and there are certain
principles that guide uh that acts as
guiding principle on how
how you make it successful yeah so
essentially uh
what i've seen is uh
even these well-defined uh products they
sort of follow agile but they're not
really agile in the sense that there's a
project plan that says three months of
development and those developments are
in iterations and then there is uh
an integration test phase and so on
right and and here is where i i would
get get a little bit on the and having
the right practice right uh
this the next statement maybe maybe a
bit debated but personally i am not a
fan of that methodology right uh what i
would like to see is as soon as we have
something it's integrated in the
production environment or in in in the
real
uh
real uh you know environment uh yes we
could turn it off for the users and
things like that but we do integrations
we do uh we build the products gradually
and you know instead of having a big
bang at the end right now
uh anyway so i think uh
i probably deviated a little bit here
but that's one uh set of products again
you know uh
uh
even though they are well defined i
think uh
following the right agile practices uh
would
would really uh
solve some of the burdens that that we
face
now
the other nature of products is is
something which is a bit ambiguous you
know
the problem space
you know that this is
what we are trying to solve
and we do not have the solution yet but
you know the shape of the solution you
know that the solution looks something
like this and to me these are uh this is
some really exciting products to build
and in fact i mentioned about logo maker
earlier it sort of falls in this we know
that we would like to build a
world-class uh do-it-yourself logo maker
where the customers can come and with
some simple uh interactions uh we we
kind of come up with some really
beautiful and relevant logos right it so
we know that that's the problem we're
trying to solve but then there are
nuances right uh what are the customers
like what kind what kind of designs look
good uh how do you define uh
the quality of the logos um
because it's extremely subjective and
how do you know uh
what will the customers like very often
what i like may not be the same as what
the customers like and all these kind of
uh
ambiguous nature really makes way for
some exciting uh phase of product
development right so it is extremely
important in such scenarios uh to bake
in experimentation as a part of your
your process right as in you're building
the product by running a lot of little
experiments and seeing how
it works what works well and you pivot
accordingly and again mind you these are
not like you know mindless experiments
or just some random experiments right
the typical thing where you form you
form a hypo you observe something you
form a hypothesis then you you sort of
implement something real quick test it
and based on what you observe you go to
the next step right and and and this
essentially uh gives a sense of the
evolution of a product right it's you do
something simple and you evolve you
adjust based on the market needs based
on what the customers want and you
evolve it uh so those are some of if you
look at some of the great products uh
that is roughly how it would have
evolved give or take a few uh details
right and
the good thing for me uh from my
perspective is that uh
the successful ones uh essentially
nurture a culture of co-creation right
it's not about
it's not about a set of instructions
that comes in from someone this is how
the product needs to be it's about
defining a vision and going after it
defining a problem statement
exploring it and then having a
conversation about how do we solve that
problem and and generally right uh
there's a lot of excitement and and i i
would think you know if you if you kind
of define and
set up your uh problem in this fashion
set up your uh product objective in this
fashion
and you follow these they follow this
approach right the approach of
experimentation the approach of being
nimble the approach of having
a co-creation sort of an environment
there is a very strong chance that you
will stumble you will evolve it into a
really great product because you're sort
of doing all the right things it's like
you're sculpting the product and you're
and you have everyone doing the right
things there right so so for me i think
this is the crux of building
a world-class product right understand
the problem uh define it
have this practice have this process of
you know
just staying focused on it and
continually adjusting and build a team
and build a culture of experimentation
and just doing the right things this
will eventually lead into some really uh
good products
now
i want to do a i would sort of have a
segue between that to to
multiple times i mentioned about
creation cooperation and so on and and
and i think that's where uh
it it it
transitions into how do you become
world-class developer right and and this
is where the question really for you is
as a developer would you want to be
someone who takes instructions uh
so to speak
or
are you a creator right in the sense
that do you want to be someone who who
is being told it could be by business it
could be by a product manager it could
be by someone
in the sense hey i want you to do this
this is the problem this is like you
know this is a solution you implemented
this day so you are do you want to be an
implementer of it
or do you want to be a co-creator do you
want to be someone who has a
participation in how the product evolves
and
for me uh the best developers that i
have seen have the mindset for the
latter right so you are you you're not
just taking instructions you're really
trying to contribute to the product and
and i think that that really is a
hallmark of one of the hallmarks of how
uh someone could be a great uh developer
and this is uh you know across this
again
even though i'm talking about a product
which is you know evolving and so on the
statement is true even if your product
is not like that even if product is much
simpler much straightforward even there
there is an opportunity for you to
contribute in the creation of it in the
in in the way uh that there are things
that could be done better and
and i think you should
my advice would be as a developer or as
any con any uh team player in in the in
the team
uh to look for those look for how you
could contribute in creating the
solution and i think that's what's going
to set you apart and really take your
you to the next level
um
all right so moving on uh again you know
uh
so as to so i would just move on to the
to the uh so how do you be uh
essentially the traits of a world-class
developers right and and
one thing i've already mentioned which
is about how could you be co-created but
then
a lot of times um i i think there is
this uh uh there's a good chance that
some of you might be uh thinking about
that each other hey i have these ideas i
have i want things to be done but
uh
maybe my manager is not listening to me
or maybe uh no one in the team listens
to me or something like that right
and it's quite possible right in in a in
a dynamic work environment sometimes it
could happen uh especially if the
culture of the team is not that involved
right uh and not that it worked to be
inclusive and things like that right and
and to an extent right i think uh there
is there are things that you could do
and you know it's in your hands uh to
build credibility right uh and
in
from what i can say right if i trace
back uh to some of the great developers
that i have worked with uh and you or
even the time when uh let's say i felt i
did something really wonderful
uh one of the biggest things uh that
comes to mind is about being the showing
bias to action right it's one thing to
keep talking about things but it's it's
a different thing to take an initiative
and and and do something uh again
uh don't get me wrong i'm not
necessarily saying that hey solve the
whole thing or you know
stretch beyond your time and put
work 20 hours a day and put something
right that's that's not what i am i'm
referring to right i'm just referring to
that little nudge about hey you know
maybe you could just build a little
prototype and there's a or you see as
you see something
uh you see something uh it could be
small problem you see that lying around
and you take action you have you show
bias to action instead of talking about
it you do something about it it could be
something very it could be a very small
act
but i think that's where it starts right
showing a bias to action is probably one
of the uh one of the significant
contributors to for someone to build
credibility and once you build
credibility uh your ability and your
the strength of your influence
automatically improves right and and
again uh that's what it's all about if
you're co-creating you you've got to be
able to influence your ideas you got to
be able to
present your ideas in a way that can be
accepted and and and of course it has to
be the right idea in the first place and
and you do that by building credibility
right uh
so yeah i mean uh
show bias to action
and
also just take initiative right don't
wait don't uh you gotta stop asking for
permission or seeking permission right
if there's an opportunity just go for it
right
and this is how you eventually build
your personal brand
right so
yeah so just to summarize right you know
um
seek that
that joy of creation seek that space
where you could co-create and seek that
uh you know and build your credibility
right and build your credibility by
showing bias to action by picking simple
things
now
uh in the past when i have mentioned
this i have heard
responses on the lines of
say i i do uh show my bias to action but
i am not appreciated i am still not
being recognized
uh and things like that right i am still
not able to build my credibility i am
still nobody listens to me uh it could
happen right
and again there are various reasons
right it could have to do with uh
you're not at least that stage where you
know it's strong enough uh i would still
say just
you know keep working at it right you
will you will crack it right it's just a
matter of time uh and at the end of the
day it's not about
that one
job or one
project right it's about you it's about
how you as a
how you show up essentially right uh and
uh
typically if you uh once you hone that
ability it stays with you right it
becomes a part of you and and
irrespective if it doesn't work in one
environment it will work in another
environment right so uh so yeah just
just don't shy from it at the end of the
day by doing this you're obviously
helping your organization you're
obviously helping your product
everything but you're also helping
yourself you're all you're building your
own um capability and you know
so
yeah so
just just
take ownership and act right
the next set of things uh yeah uh i
would talk about is uh about your your
mindset right again don't be afraid to
be wrong
uh
and also don't be afraid to admit that
you're wrong uh and again i have heard
that certain environments this may uh
not work very well
so your mileage may vary but as a
general principle right so the more uh
the more vocally self-critical you are
it again helps with building credibility
right it helps in building uh it it
clearly demonstrates that while you have
your strong opinions you you also not
afraid to be to admit that you're wrong
which further builds the credibility
because you know if you've done
something wrong you'll be the first one
to raise hands oops that that was not
right
uh again it's it's usually important to
have uh it is important to have that
psychological safety around it that
enables it uh but again you know uh it's
uh
and and if you are if you do not have an
environment where you could do it
there's something wrong with the culture
there right uh so uh again
take your right judgment call but
what i have seen works well most is when
you embrace this mindset right because
now you i
now you know you're not
you're not dependent on anything right
you know
you you are self-aware and and i think
that kind of helps in in taking you a
long way right you could you hold
yourself accountable to others right so
and and that sort of really uh
again uh
shows you in a very good light right
because uh
of course others can point out a mistake
but you'll be the first to point out
your own mistake and that sort of
grounds you but also uh you know
elevates you in in a very paradoxical
sense right uh
and i i know a lot of these things that
i i talked about is about uh behaviors
but then uh another important thing and
i'm not
specifically talked about technology but
uh and that's what i'm gonna do right
now uh
so keep learning keep learning new
things right
and of course there are various uh
forums to learn uh it could be little
webinars like this but of course uh this
is gonna be a very high level i'm gonna
talk about a few things but then you
know a fine mechanisms where you could
learn about the things that you like
things that you would enjoy there are
in the current world i think there are a
lot of good uh sources available
including simply learn uh and and there
are so many other uh sources available
for for you to to pick things and learn
right so uh and that's again you know uh
the more you know the more you learn
about things the more variations the
more the more range of things that you
are aware of that you learn uh it
eventually helps in the first point we
talked about solving a problem uh it it
opens up your mind in uh
for for various ways in which a given
problem could be solved right so and
again it helps you
with building your credibility
uh another important thing i would say
is you know uh
relentlessly collaborate with people
around a network and collaborate with
them right the people your colleagues
and you know your stakeholders
beat anyone right collaborate with them
and generally care about them right so
genuinely care about the people uh that
you work with uh because i think
subconsciously we see through a fake uh
thing right if somebody is faking uh
that uh the care you eventually see
through it right so the the right thing
really is to generally care about them
and what it translates here is about uh
having the right empathy uh supporting
uh your colleagues when uh they need
help
uh and
and the support could come in various
formats right it could come and if there
is somebody struggling with something
you could
offer a helping hand or it could be
something else you know
everyone is different but but sure that
you genuinely care about people right
and and and uh
collaborate with you know with all your
stakeholders with open mind and i think
this this really uh
will help in you growing as an engineer
going growing as a collab as a developer
uh
related to that is about you know uh
have a growth mindset which is about uh
essentially uh seek for feedback
and accept let's see uh you know accept
feedback i think i think there's a
really uh
beautiful someone has put it very uh
beautifully which is about feedback is a
gift right
and you know especially when someone is
giving you a critical feedback or a
feedback about something that is not
easy uh you should appreciate that
even more because it's not easy to give
difficult feedback now with and whether
you agree with that or not is
secondary right the primary thing is be
open to feedback and seek for feedback
and any feedback do not dismiss it right
it has something
uh something behind that um and
this essentially will give you more
essentially give more data points and
inputs about how how you would like to
improve yourself right uh and the more
you know uh the more you see
if not anything else even if if it's a
conjecture if even if it's not a fact it
will still allow you to work on your
empathy because if
so and so is concluding this about me
there's something uh wrong that am doing
there's something about the way i
uh you know come across is not right
let me work on it right so so so i mean
i'm saying i'm just talking about the
extreme scenario where you do not agree
with the feedback and of course if you
agree with the feedback uh even better
you know there's something something
that
that you know you could work on uh this
does not mean that you blindly agree
with every feedback and you know you
you've got to apply your own thought
process around it and and if you're not
sure you know uh seek your seek your
mentor's uh input on that right here
this is what
uh the feedback i'm getting what do you
think right and and and you know bounce
off uh those idea those thought and and
and you'll get the right uh input but
essentially uh the underlying uh um uh
comment here is about having a a growth
mindset right and being being
emotionally honest about yours
about about yourself uh being candid in
receiving feedback and also being candid
in giving feedback right
giving and the same feedback is one of
the
one of the most critical things that you
could learn as a professional uh
i would and if you're already great at
it uh kudos uh and uh just sure i mean i
i think actually learning right i've
gotten good at some part of it but i'm
still learning i still have a long way
to go because it's there's so much to it
so i would say what i would advise is if
you are already good at it great keep
working on it and if you're not uh
really think about it right uh
how how you could give a good feedback
uh to others and how you could uh
essentially uh have the right frame of
mind to receive uh valuable feedback
um again just not to go too deep into it
but there are certain things right about
uh
especially when you're giving critical
feedback remember that the feedback is
not about the person it's about
something that the person did and it's
very important to differentiate the two
else it will not be candid anymore it
just becomes personal and and the the
odds of someone listening to your
feedback just drops drastically right
and hence i'm saying it's a it's a craft
it's it's it's a it's it's something
that you get better at
what i would strongly suggest you do not
is you know
stop
being be very genuine in the feedback
right
it's i would say it's better to not give
any feedback than give an incorrect
feedback give a false feedback a sugar
coated just for the sake of it
or give a feedback which absolutely does
not do anything uh it's it's it's not
very useful right uh anyways i will i
will not detour much further about
feedback but i would i would strongly
recommend learn more about giving and
receiving feedback right um yeah and and
the other thing you could do essentially
is you know uh connect and surround
yourself with folks who are better than
you
if not in everything maybe certain
things you don't always have to be the
smartest person in the room right uh
it's it's it's it's valuable uh for you
uh if there are folks who are equally or
more smarter than you uh which is an
opportunity to learn uh and i think a
lot of
my experience i mean i could watch for
that right uh
you you and then the look and learning
is not necessarily just from
it's not always from seniors right i
mean there are times that i learned a
lot from someone who would join the team
or who started working very recently
right uh you got to have an open mind
and to sort of literally listen what
what they say anyways uh so uh yeah
surround yourself with with really smart
people and try uh who who are better
than you and you know you're gonna
position yourself very well uh when you
do that
uh
the other thing i i guess you know a
typical uh thing that i
uh
like you know in in the several years
that uh we have been giving feedback
right one other thing that usually comes
up quite often is about communication
uh like poor communication is an input
given but then uh communication
obviously means a lot of it doesn't it's
not just about being
[Music]
being talkative or uh
speaking is one way of it but then it's
not just about that right communication
could mean a lot of there are a lot of
different ways even just because someone
is an introvert does not mean that they
are not good communicators right i have
i know a lot of people who are by nature
not outspoken per se not uh they're sort
of a little
introverted but they're excellent
communicators right so communication so
let's not mix communication with with
talent
again it's a very broad thing right but
recognize the need to communicate right
uh
first of all right
at the fundamental level right if you
don't communicate if you do not speak up
no one can read your mind right uh very
very very few people are good at that
in general i think it's safe to assume
that if you do not speak up about
something uh the odds
are there that
they do not have the same thing that it
is in your mind and i can give
multiple examples but one significant
example that comes to my mind is uh
there's one aspiration that i had
and this is way way like almost 17 18
years ago
and
uh
that was not happening and i went to
kind of confirm the manager and they
said hey you know this is not happening
is there something wrong with the way
i'm doing things
and the only feedback i got from man is
okay i never realized that you had that
aspiration i did because you never told
me about it right so let me work on it
and as soon as i had the conversation
very shortly uh things worked out right
and i was in this space whereas
where i was like hey
why is this not happening why is this
not happening and the mistake i did
there was i never communicated i never
uh i assumed that my manager in that
case would know what i want right uh and
yeah don't do that mistake right if
there is anything that you want uh speak
up and you know verbalize it just make
sure that you are communicating about it
and letting some letting someone know
that hey this is what you have in mind
right
uh
and and you know communicate up and
wide right as in you know
you can
communications you know you communicate
with your managers you communicate with
your peers with your stakeholders and
everyone uh
have simple thumbnails don't assume that
people can read your mind
they definitely cannot right uh so just
just
find the right uh
communication i think that right
all right um
and i think i would sort of start
wrapping this up a little bit here right
uh
one of the things that again these are
few things that i
what i spoke about is things that i
value in in
in developers
uh
to me one of the most important things
is is integrity and and you saw how i
was talking about genuine feedback
genuinely care about people
um and
take feedback with open mind communicate
all the things right uh and eventually
all this to me it comes with uh
it comes to the point of having a very
strong integrity right and i've seen the
people who have very strong integrity
are the ones who uh who have seen like
immense success
uh
mean what you say right i mean don't do
don't hide behind the political
correctness be very straightforward
right uh again it creates it comes to
about feedback and so on and there are
there are times when you
uh
especially the difficult conversations
right you try to
have it in a way where you make it
non-confrontational
for all right reasons but then if the
message is not clearly communicated
across and you try to use political
correctness or you sugarcoat the
feedback
or the message it's you're actually
doing a harm rather than good right so
be very clear uh mean what you say and
again you know uh so it's not just about
saying uh also about um
in other things right if you say
something
do it right don't
don't get into this but hey but i did
not say that
you know if even though you even though
you know you have said something
and never get into this business of okay
hey there is no proof of it so now i can
play it the other way right uh don't do
that i mean you know uh it's a short
term win but a long-term loss right uh
you won't get away with that for for too
long maybe in this one situation you
will get away but very soon you know it
will chase you right so i think
integrity is one of the most important
things that you could have as a
developer probably not just as a
developer as a professional right uh
professional integrity uh it to me it's
at the top of one of the top things that
uh that i would look for and i would uh
i would value
uh
and and you know let your principles
guide you right in terms of you know you
have of course you we all have our own
value system but then let that guide you
in terms of how you want to approach the
situation and if you have strong set of
principles and strong integrity you will
do the right thing
um and and and that's what culminates in
to be genuine right the if you're
genuine in this in in various situations
uh the right version of you comes out
right and and that's brilliant
uh
with that i think you know
um
maybe i'll probably just talk about i i
spoke a lot about the things that
you do i would just uh talk about a
couple of things that i think should not
do right uh there's one a very
interesting thing
it's very common it's very uh
uh
natural
for a lot of us to assume uh
uh
malice right saying that hey this person
we call the office politics and and so
on
uh
i would not say that the office politics
does not exist probably does in some
pockets but i think it's it is
it is given more credit than it deserves
right in the sense that there are a lot
of things that it's just
simple dynamics and that's attributed to
malice that's attributed to politics and
so on and i think that's that's not the
case right i mean in fact there is this
thing called have launched razor which
which codes never attribute to malays
that which can be adequately explained
by stupidity uh you know
in general people are not scheming
things of course there may be an
exception right so so if something goes
wrong it's probably you know they were
stupid enough to not see something right
uh of course there are exceptions i you
know i'm sure i'm i'm
uh guessing that unfortunately some of
you might have been impacted by uh
uh
by this and if uh and genuinely so and
so it could happen but i would say
that's not necessarily the default right
so so don't be in that you know in that
victim frame that you know you're always
you're being targeted uh the odds of
that is low it could happen but it's low
right and hence do not be cynical or
vindictive or manipulative or revengeful
in your approach it's not worth it i
mean even if somebody has
screwed up stood with you or whatever
right it's
it it's not worth being cynical right
even you could either fix that fix
things or you could just
move on with it
now this comes with a bit of a pinch of
salt i know there are
situations or there are certain personal
values uh which which could be different
from it that's okay right uh but in
general right uh
yeah so don't be in that victim frame
you know
there are a lot of just if you don't
like
the things that are going on if if
things are too negative around you i
would say just change the environment
right
uh
and and and lastly right uh
uh well all these things that are said
and done uh
work life balance and or work like
integration as it's called right now is
extremely important
uh don't work too hard it's a marathon
it's not a sprint right
you've got years and years and years of
things to be
done uh take care of your health uh find
fights and things to do outside of your
work right
so uh so yeah just remember that work is
not everything it's extremely important
part of your life but it's not
everything
uh so yeah i mean work life balance is
important right and and seek that and
and even if you can work more just just
see when where you want to draw the line
and you know have that right balance
uh so yeah so i think those are some of
the things that i value
and i've seen some really accomplished
developers
with these uh behaviors with these kind
of mindset uh and i hope this was
helpful some of it might repeat because
it's you know you would have probably
heard it in from from different forums
but uh i could vouch for the things that
i just described here
uh with that uh stuart uh over to you
thanks everyone for listening
great um we can um
fell into the questions and answers that
was a
really great
talk
red vendread we had a lot of comments
coming in about
how helpful that was to folks um
and
just taking a look at my
screen here
we've got
wade who asks how how did somebody get
started in software development
um
not necessarily i think his question is
not necessarily how do you get started
as a software developer
but how do you decide where to start
when you're developing a software
product
oh
um
let me see if i understood the question
correctly it's more about
is the question more around when you
actually start writing code and start
building software for something is do
you think that is that the spirit of the
question
i think the spirit of the question yeah
is is
you know when you're
working on a product
you know what it where do you start
you know approaching the problem and
what steps do you start with yeah so i
think it's it's an interesting thing
right you know because you know i i did
speak quite a bit about understanding
the problem and so on uh but then i also
spoke about bias to action which is a
bit contra contrary to this and that you
know what you do not want to do is just
even though it is important to define
the problem absolutely uh what it should
not be uh
doing is i think there's a term called
analysis paralysis right where you keep
thinking about it and so on right
and i i guess the balance right you know
you continue to define the problem right
you don't stop that until you have the
right problem definition at the same
time as soon as you have something uh
that that
that feels
good enough right
it is it you could start prototyping it
right you could start sort of
building building things out so that you
could learn more about it right as in
let's say something as simple as you
know let's say uh
we have this problem we think this sort
of a website or this sort of uh app will
solve the problem right
while the problem discovery is happening
you could form a hypothesis around hey
this looks like this is the way we could
solve it for the problem uh it is very
useful to build a quick quick and dirty
prototype a low fidelity prototype is
perfectly fine but then you have started
right so you have started the chain of
iterations right uh
what i meant earlier by about be
driven by the problem is that don't let
the solution then drive the problems so
that is the difference right
stay focused on the problem but then i
would say build start building as early
as possible
recognizing that the early stages the
purpose of bodybuild early is a bit
different from something down the line
right the purpose here is to learn more
about it to discover more about the
problem or or maybe to just prove or
disprove some hypotheses right
so i think that that's where you would
start
and then i think it leads into the
design and technology choices as well
and
in the longer run it is important to
choose the right technology it is
important to use the right stack and
everything but then don't get bogged
down by it right so uh
even uh and i i i that's why i would
just point to the point uh to the note
of bias to action uh i would say
whenever whatever the earliest
opportunity to put start putting
something together i think it would be
good to start doing it recognizing that
it may change
does that uh
i hope that answers the question if not
i'm happy to you know
i i think that that answers the question
is
i
learned engineering
way back in the days of the waterfall
project management
discipline
where you didn't start building
something until you had a product
specification that was
completely laid out in every detail
and you know you look at the difference
today
and you can look at the difference
between
something that isn't strictly product
software development but look look at
the difference between boeing
corporation
and spacex corporation
in how they approach
building
systems to take human beings into orbit
and beyond um
boeing is
from very much from the tradition of
we get a government specification we
have to write everything out before we
start putting pen to paper on design
spacex is
we'll build a rocket and if it
crashes if it blows up as long as nobody
gets hurt we learn something from that
and we can
iterate it ending
so it's it's
it's a
different world than the one i was born
into
but i i i could relate to what he just
said to it and also i think
the difference is about the time uh to
build uh an aircraft of course now it's
already built in small
evolutions rather than completely
redesigned versus the time spacex took
right is significantly different it was
much smaller time frame and that is
because of this this agility that you
sort of described very nicely there
yeah and and and
the interesting proof is that spacex has
been delivering dragon
capsules to the international space
station for several years now and boeing
just recently
made its first successful
test of the starlink capsule
and you would think
based on the size and experience of the
organizations it would be completely
opposite so yes
that that bias to action and the
agility and willingness to
iterate is very important um
lck asks a question uh about whether the
covid era has changed how
you create products
now a very interesting question um i
think
to an extent yes uh and again there are
a lot of
different views to it and i'm saying
mine is a view a quick disclaimer it's
not necessarily backed by
research or anything of that sort uh
it's just based on uh anecdotal
experiences right uh i think it has
right uh of course there are things
about
one of them one of the significant
things is around
uh
inherently right i think working from
home is a bit less structured than
working from office
um in this uh in the sense that uh how
you approach things right has has become
a bit more agile and bit more
unstructured but yet focused right in
the sense
like like my or for example right we do
not have specified work hours per se
right but then yet when i work or when
my team works they're really focused
about about this and this
this sort of uh
not enforcing uh
rigid structures actually uh
helping i mean it's actually working out
very well uh so that's one element of it
uh second element i think is is the the
talent pool or you know because folks
can work from anywhere i think it is it
is significantly improved the talent
pool available and
what also happened was uh
it forced
uh forced companies organizations to
think different in terms of how we could
collaborate right uh the fact that uh
coming to office is not necessary i
think i think was quite
there are exceptions of course don't
take this as a general statement
it has made way for for for some really
uh
a different way of working a lot of
companies are uh
embracing this whole remote first inking
trading like simple actually is remote
first uh and a lot of other companies
are doing it and it's important to do it
right it's important to follow the right
uh
essentially re-imagine the way we work
um so coming back to the original
question i think it has
uh in a way it has fast tracked uh if if
covet had not happened maybe we would
have eventually stumbled upon something
like this
but it has fast tracked the way uh
work happens
and there are a lot of debates around
whether it's
the productivity has gone up or gone
down and so on my view my personal view
i think the productivity is great
uh there are certain things around you
know some of the inter in person
interactions are reduced and there are
some on the water cooler chats and or
some of the opportunity to mentor
on the fly has reduced uh which which i
think is is on the negative side but
other than that i think
yeah my view is going great
yeah there used to be a
expression management by walking around
referring to
how you would be able to
monitor
and learn about what your
your subordinates are doing by
wandering through their
work areas and having chats with them
and
you can't do that uh in the in a remote
situation nearly as well yeah but but
it's really about giving up the illusion
of control right i mean what you
described just now is an illusion of
control that
that you exercise on your subordinates
and and of course in some situation it
is necessary but i think in general
right that
yeah i i i visualize there is this movie
called office space where you know
holds the mug and walks around the
office that's what i visualize when you
are describing that stuart
yeah exactly and that's the meme
everybody sees was with the boss looking
over the
edge of the cubicle and saying it would
be great if you could do this right
he's always asking for something
completely unreasonable uh
but we have a
question from edward who says he's a
terrible self-learner how do you how
would you deal with a problem like that
oh okay um
i i think the the problem is in in in
itself what you call the the problem is
identified in the statement right i
think
i i think it's about yeah i see your
point uh i i think
there's this inertia thing right i'll do
it tomorrow or procrastination and
things like that
uh
there's
i would suggest you got to you know
maybe just show bias to action there
right just start something small right
uh and i think
set some small objectives uh it's always
it always helps to have some
i think some problem you're solving that
typically fast tracks you're learning
rather than like if i had to learn
something about data science right maybe
i'll do it maybe i will not but if i'm
solving if i'm working on a problem that
requires me to learn about data science
then it aligns
well
so if you're not a self-starter probably
you could start the other way around
where
you you uh you commit to solving a
problem that needs you to learn
something so it could be small but that
might be a way uh but yeah each uh each
everyone is different it's your a bit a
bit individualistic on how you approach
it but
i think that's something that you might
try
yeah it also helps if you if you're if
you recognize that
learning on your own
is difficult for you you can always look
for situations where you can have a
mentor a guide a coach
a teacher
so
it's one of the things
it's simply we we have
courses that are available that are
completely self-study
and then we have other courses where
you're you're part of a cohort
and getting live virtual classrooms so
that you're interacting
live with the professor you're able to
interact with your peers and that type
of thing and it depends on your your
learning style and
you know what you need out of uh a
course um
mirage
in our youtube audience asks which is
more important degree
or knowledge when you're looking to get
a job
degree or knowledge
a disclaimer it's a personal opinion so
uh i i think knowledge
uh
yeah it's a
again it's a personal opinion um
degree in a way right it's
see it's usually the case right degree
is something it's
the problem is that you cannot it's
difficult to judge knowledge on its own
right so degree is a sort of a
standardized way to judge that you are
capable of doing certain things and and
i think that's what that's as far as a
degree goes uh beyond that it's you
right i mean i think beyond certain
stage it's really about your knowledge
of course the degree would have helped
uh
even even even you know just a little
thing around
there i i hear about
uh
those in engineering schools talking
about hey i had this 30 subjects but i
am not gonna i don't use a single one of
them when i start working uh so what
it's probably a waste of time and so on
uh
it probably wasn't like you know if you
look at a a a very different analogy
right uh you'll when you when kids learn
about rhymes uh you know uh
like
on the television uh so uh the wheels on
the bus so
old macdonald and so on uh
we absolutely have we don't use it after
a few years and there's no way we're
gonna
that's helpful but then at that stage
that
that was helpful for you to learn
certain things and it's a very similar
kind of a thing when you're when you're
in a college
it what it actually is telling you is
one it's allowing you to try out
different things you are building a
skill of learning things fast you know
it's very fast-paced right in in about
four to five months you need to learn
about six subjects give several exams
about it and so on even though the
knowledge itself may or may not be
useful
uh your ability to grasp things fast
your ability to learn things fast is
something that is very valuable and you
know you would apply that um in your
professional life so that may be another
perspective to think about you know
what you're doing in you know how things
that you've done in the past is valuable
to you
and we have a number of related
questions that have to do uh we have uh
bargov for example is a
lawyer who's already in a well-developed
career earning good salary but he's
interested in transitioning to software
development and we have other people who
are
from mechanical background or a
mathematical background
who are looking to move
into data science or into develop
software development um
so what do you
what advice do you have for someone who
is
working and wants to make that kind of a
career pivot what are some of the steps
that they can take to do that um i think
a couple of things right i mean if you
in fact even today right
for the majority i
have not spoken about technology i
haven't spoken about data science or
learning about others right for the most
part i have spoken about certain
behavioral traits or certain certain uh
things that you could embrace which is
irrespective of what your current
background is right anything i think all
these things anyone can pick it up there
will be certain things around okay how
like the whole concept of a product and
the software iterations is something
that you probably need to uh to
understand if you do not have a
background like that and and i i think
those are learnable right and it's and
there are various ways there are
obviously all these really good courses
and things like that but but uh
yeah i mean you know um just again try
and
find yourself in a place where you can
solve a real problem right it could be
through internship or it could be
through
uh
under someone's mentorship or it could
be just something that you do on your
own and and i think from a skill
standpoint that would be the way to
transition
uh
what i mean is you know that would that
would be the way to acquire those skills
uh the next bit of a bit of a challenge
is around how do you like let's say you
have a completely different background
uh how do you uh
how do you get a job in in software for
example right um
unfortunately i do not think i have some
really good advice to add there uh i
think it is gonna be a bit of a hustle
but there are you know it's definitely
possible i know if people have done that
uh
they've done it with different things
right you again it comes to about how
you build your credibility uh you in in
this case you know you you acquired
those skills you found a way to uh to
display those skills you you have tapped
onto your network and you know and
started with something small and then
you know built on it so that's what i
have seen people do it uh but again it's
not an area where of my expertise so i
would ever defer to someone you know the
career transition part the skill
acquiring i can talk more about it but
the transition is a bit
nuanced there yeah it's possible for
sure
yeah one of the challenges for people
who are making a career pivot
from an established career in whatever
field into a new career in a different
field is recognizing that you may end up
taking a step back in terms of
seniority salary that type of thing in
order to get your foothold in the new
career
but
a lot of what you've learned
from your experience can be translated
into
your management skills your your skills
in the workplace and that type of thing
so
exactly and one more thing
right i think someone mentioned uh their
lawyer right and obviously yeah that
they could bring in the domain expertise
into the software like you know you
could if not directly as a developer you
could enter as a domain expert through a
product and then transition that maybe
i've seen that transition also happen so
yeah yeah
yeah it's an interesting thing a number
of years ago about like 10 15 maybe
longer
a group of very famous lawyers in the
united states including people who
represented o.j simpson in his trial
which was a big
big issue in the united states but some
of those lawyers got together and
decided that
there was an opportunity to create a
self-service legal
services for things like creating
wills and trust documents and and other
kinds of
standard agreements and that type of
thing that they formed a company called
legalzoom and they came from the
background of
deep domain experience in the law
and
so gaining
the skills in technology
and cross
crossing that with your skills in a in a
domain can often be a very powerful way
to create a new
career and even a new business sometimes
that makes sense and if i make related i
think it's it's i think it's it's
analogous to the problem defining the
problem space right because you're in
the domain you understand the problem
and you found a niche problem that needs
to be solved and you and that is your
entry point there
that is a good uh example of that to it
thank you um
arton asks uh we're gonna get experience
with open source projects what are some
of the places that you would direct
people to
to participate in open source
um
i have seen people participate in the
standard apache
open source projects
uh
my there are a few members from my team
who had done that like when we were
working on some problem when we found uh
on an issue of some
we raised a pull request in those
projects and did that
um i'm not quite sure like what do you
mean by you know
uh
like i don't think i got the spirit of
the question there
i i think that
things like um i think there's a firm
hacker earth that allows
people to
find participate in open source
challenges contribute their
things like that um
and i know that there are other
you know public uh forums yeah where
where people can
you know
find an open source
project that people are collaborating on
and they can join that team
i think my most of the time that i
my team members
on the standard application projects
where you know
again it's very similar to what you what
you described but the mechanism was more
around
it is more around we are using the
framework and we found ways to improve
it and so we put the request back uh but
yeah i'm sure there are more proactive
ways of contributing to that as well
yeah okay
um we're a little overtime so i think
that's the time for all the questions
that we have
um i want to apologize to everybody
whose questions we could not get to
but
you can always follow up with uh
through me or directly with red vendor
through his linkedin page
and i'm going to put that information up
for you in just a second here
and
actually let me
go ahead
and get to the end
and
so moving on
there is his linkedin i'm going to put
this into the chat so that you don't
have to copy it off the screen
unless you're watching on the
youtube
which case you do have to copy it off
the screen
but for our live audience
all right here we go
that's in the chat
and i wanted again to thank rug vendrick
for
a really excellent
um
presentation for a
very informative
and generous sharing of his knowledge
and we'll close by talking about one you
know people have asked about how you can
become
a
developer we do have a number of
programs that simply learn one of them
is the full stack java developer masters
program
which is something designed for people
who have
some knowledge and
background in
in programming a bit of work experience
and want to get into
this field it's a comprehensive six
month online boot camp it only takes
about 10 hours a week or so
and it's one that covers a whole variety
of tools and platforms
and
it has
live virtual classrooms so you're not
learning on your own it's not a
self-study program it's a
cohort based study program that has a
number of hands-on projects and
integrated labs allowing you to
demonstrate your
ability to
use each of the skills you learn
and you culminate in a capstone project
that takes all of those skills and puts
them together in solving a business
related problem
building a
a web solution for a business related
problem it also includes for for people
in indian united states various levels
of job assistance to help you get into
the field
once you've
completed the certificate program
so
just have one question
for this audience that
just want to get a basic temperature
question on
whether something of this nature is of
interest to you
i'll just give you about uh 30 seconds
or so to answer that
and if it is of interest to you is
something that you want you'd like to
start right away or is this something
that
you see yourself doing
sometime down the road
and
just leave this open for a few few more
seconds
and we'll close the poll get your
answers in
excellent and
just let you know how you're
peers answered about 75 percent of the
people responding said they would like
to
find out more about the program
and about 40 would like to do it
sometime within the next
few months so
you can do that by contacting me or by
contacting ask us at simplylearn.net
i'll put
that email into the chat as well
and
ask us simplylearn.net connects you to
learning counselors who can answer
everything about the program
and if you email me instead then i'll
just point you to them so
and our next
webinar in this series is
one week from today it is
with vijay randrandrum who is a founder
of
data that matters llc
he is a
cdo chief data officer and he is
an expert in the field of data
management and
more than data management
data
organization management so
for anyone who out there is a um
is interested in
becoming a chief data officer down the
road or if you know someone who is in
that field
i just want to
put that into the chat as well
and we'd love to see you at that webinar
as well
last thing i'll put into the chat is a
link to the full stack
webpage
thank you all for being here today uh
thank you again rick vendra for
uh being so generous with your time and
knowledge
thank you it's my pleasure
and
with that we invite everyone to
follow us on our
social channels uh simply learn on
facebook on twitter and simply learn on
linkedin
and with that
let's conclude the webinar
you